- So you also have, is it
called self-care Sunday?
- I do.
I do self-care Sunday.
- I love this.
So what is a self-care Sunday?
What do you do?
- So, it's like definitely a bath.
- [Kelly] I love a bath.
- And it's definitely like,
there's crystals involved.
I'll listen to a meditation.
(Kelly gasps)
- You just sent out one
of those bath balls.
It's like Mer, is it?
It smells so good.
- [Jessica] Yeah.
- I cannot wait to take a bath with that.
- [Jessica] It's so nice.
So it's like this calming
and I put on a face mask.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- [Jessica] And like sometimes
my kids will join in.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- [Jessica] You know,
it's just like a nice thing to do
where it doesn't feel like,
oh, that's mom's thing.
And like, you know, or else I'll get,
you know, resistance,
but I'm like, join me and
self care Sunday, guys.
- Self care Sunday.
- Let's like not scream at each other
and be chill today.
- And meditate with our mask on.
- [Jessica] Yeah.
(Kelly laughs).
- I love that.
So if you, I love that.
And if you were busy enough, I love this.
So now you have, you have a
children's book too, right?
And it's,
- Yes.
- [Kelly] And it's called
"Bear to Share" right?
- "Bear to Share". Yeah.
So in honor of our 10 year anniversary,
the nonprofit that I work
with is baby to baby.
And um it really, you know, baby to baby
is this awesome organization.
We scaled it in really
to a national and even
global organization to really
provide basic essentials
for families in need.
So when you buy something
from honest, you are
supporting our effort to
give back to baby to baby.
And part of this book was
the same thing we wanted to
teach kids.
You know, it's hard to teach
kids compassion and giving
especially like they
just know what they know.
Right. - Yeah.
And so this book really, and
- Especially with a lot of
adults walking out without none.
So without any, you know, like compassion
without any compassion
or envy, you're like
I swear it's there.
- So this book is really
like a way to kind of,
tell that story
and make meaning for children.
So they understand, you know,
the importance of giving back
but then also like seeing
others who may not have
everything the way that you
do or may have different life
circumstances. So
- I love that my kids are gonna love it.
I love the cover art.
Yeah. It's captivating it's cool.
Yeah.
- We wanted to make sure
also that our main character
you know, looks like
girls that aren't the
stars of very many books.
And so is
- Like, I love that
- She's, she's Afro Latina
and she's beautiful.
I love it.
She's just like cool and
I just, it reminds me
of those little balls.
I used to wear those all the time
in my braids when I was
a kid, the little balls.
Did you ever do that?
And then you twist it,
I used to love those.
Just had a little bit of
nostalgia there from an.